[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
oh my gosh welcome back to the break
room this is our daily show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news that
you need to know and it's friday thank
goodness it's friday uh if there was a
god i would thank them but they don't
exist don't worry about it uh welcome to
the show we're gonna go over
today uh what are we talking about on
the show today well who incepted bruce
banner into shanghai
is that white smoke i see coming from
the warner brothers discovery chimneys
have they found themselves a new hope uh
and these she-hulk mfrs act like they
forgot about faye oh that's a good one
that's a good one
did you write that yeah i wrote that one
good job uh and of course we're talking
about fantastic four getting a new daddy
oh let's hope it goes somewhere great uh
hey i'm brandon but i'm not the only one
here today we also have koi jandra on
the show today yeah i love fan casting i
was so excited oh yeah this is your kind
of thing you love it
here i said way too many times he sent
so many names i cut it down in a third
he's got three times he's got the main
characters he's got background
characters picked out right yeah he's
ready i already wrote it for the guy
that's great because uh the discussion
today is thinly written
don't spoil the ghosts for the gander
that's how that saying goes we also have
anna vincent on the show today i'm the
goose and the gander and i'm
full of the forbidden jello
forbidden jellyfish it's kicking in it's
kicking in i don't know what this is
referencing it's very j-e-l-l oh no uh
hey and right next to me he's usually
behind the camera but we let him out of
his cage we undid his shackles that's
john costa catch me in that new movie
beast beast this weekend no one caught
it
or idris elba i'm both okay cool i'm
excited you're like
situation i heard they filmed that movie
they filmed that movie with the real
lion and eat yourself but it's
completely computer-generated whoa it's
crazy that's kind of crazy isn't that
crazy
uh what's that old movie that where
those people were just hanging out with
lions and they actually
yeah yeah some family well they're all
dead some real loose facts here
hey it is friday uh and thank you for
tuning in go ahead and hit that like
button if you haven't already uh in
honor of the being friday
we have a great redemption going i don't
see what's funny about that john why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you hit the
like button message deleted by moderator
i enjoyed that
you guys cannot be reading the dirty
messages well i'm trying to do a show
here okay we're all on the same page uh
so if you watch g-hunk this week good
for you uh also you probably remember
there were some revealing kind of
click-baity headlines on a web page as
part of an easter egg of she-hulk this
week so for every 50 dollars we raise in
super chats we will read off another
headline from the she-hulk website that
was too salacious for prime time
stuck together these weren't oh i can
tell you guys
some of these are rather
the triple the double h the horny
headline okay uh some of them are a
little risque they wouldn't allow them
on disney plus we got a hold of them
what's the third h
i dropped well as a fan of triple h
hunter hurst
uh look him up uh co co-creative
director of wwe uh i i have a tendency
to say triple h when only i need two h
three horny hippos hungry
these are hot horny headlines i don't
know we could throw three h's in there
but i got a fourth h for you it's
headlines hey
that was great that's great well
technically headlines was one of the h
machines
pin number trash uh drives coin nuts hey
if you see koi at the retirement homes
tell them i said hello
first headline today dan lynn is in
talks for head of dc film and television
and boy who doesn't want that job who's
that uh that's a great question john i'm
gonna tell you all right this this fella
daniel lynn he hasn't been offered the
role yet okay this is just the talks but
if the news is starting to leak out to
the big papes the trades as they say uh
it's probably pretty close and getting
the pr going uh there it's not a done
deal though there's still some obstacles
that could prevent uh this deal from
coming to fruition mainly that lin's
production company called ride back they
have current deals with competitors like
universal and disney so he's got other
stuff he needs to do but daniel and he
has worked as a producer for warner's
before he works on some of their
franchises including it yeah scary
clowns uh and the lego movie films i
want to crossover
those robert denny jr uh
homes movies getting notified
in the dc universe
i was ready to [ __ ] leave this set to
go watch that movie yeah sherlock three
available with beast
down
is so good he's banging on this attitude
harpsichord it's great
guy richie for everything guys for
everything well some of those movies
yeah
he's in sherlock excellently yeah yeah
go back to sherlock we're done anyways
next time
hercules apparently oh that's exciting
we covered that story daniel vito says
that they don't cast me that kind of
hair on there if it was the the brett
goldstein hercules oh that would i would
watch him sing sure laser hair removes
was pretty expensive
if you're an executive at disney don't
cast devito
oh because you gotta
that's your reasons you wouldn't have a
hair on your ass oh the um keep it clean
i didn't get you i figured because they
don't have courage it never grew i don't
know danny devito if you're watching
please call in tell us what you do let
us know pick up steaming blue on the way
over thank you so much hey here's a
headline for you neil gaiman he once
sabotaged a sandman film adaptation
because it was quote the worst script
i've ever read uh if you guys know
sandman finally made it to netflix
people love that is there going to be
season two we don't know was this name
joseph gordon-levitt no so there was a
version that was like written by joseph
gordon it was going to be directed by
him it didn't come about there was a
version
uh that was being produced by the
infamous john peters uh of the the uh
the kevin smith story about wanting to
put a mechanical spider and everything
oh uh he wanted to put it in superman
eventually it was
west if you saw licorice pizza this was
bradley cooper's character uh john
peters was a famous movie producer once
attached to barbra streisand a little
crazy
uh physically and emotionally attached
to her
uh so he was working on a version of uh
the sandman uh neil gaiman reads it and
his response to john peters was quote
there was nothing in there i loved there
was nothing in there i liked it
it was the worst script i've ever read
by anybody wow end quote uh and then he
hated the script so much and wanted to
sabotage it so much he sent it to ain't
it cool news all you old folks out there
in the chat will know about cool news
and it got posted there and was famously
just dragged like it was about three
triplets i think some of the characters
were triplets and they were racing for a
crown i don't know it was ridiculous but
you gotta love goat game and loving his
stuff so much that if you give him a bad
version he's gonna work to sabotage it
yeah don't sleep on that netflix show
yeah really good stuff
uh next headline uh house of the dragon
got renewed for a season two at hbo
after a very successful premiere check
out uh eric boss's breakdown of episode
one on the channel check out talking
dragons
that baby from the first episode comes
back in season
spoiler alert uh the baby will not come
back
uh unless they got a rehydration machine
on the island or something i don't know
uh but yeah we're very excited to see
them i have a feeling they were ready to
go from the jump with the second season
yeah they get good press off the first
episode and they they added momentum
so people start tuning in for episode
two i mean they had 10 million tune into
the premiere i feel like it's a classic
hbo to release that first episode and be
like hey season two is coming out but we
all know
it's a basis on the premier league they
already they already
ran the numbers the news their most
successful premiere of an original
series ever uh but i think with the news
of wb discovery kind of
cutting off projects yeah
good news they're like we still are
making things the batman and game of
thrones network the m and the rehearsal
network rehearsal season two baby can't
wait get fake angela and emmy folks
she wants an actor what a performance oh
we're about to fight and i can't do this
hey here's your next headline
mandalorian director john favreau ever
heard of him well he's teasing season
three's redemption story uh for the book
of beau effect or for the mandalorian uh
and i i i bet you can guess what it is
basically he was pretty much agreeing
that like hey the mandalores are the
mandalorians are all crazy and they have
their separate little cults
and they all have their own crazy little
rules for each other but what if they
all got together and so like this story
is going to be about
all these mandalorian groups coming
together and seeing if they can kind of
unite again get the things back on track
don't let that crazy religious stuff
ruin your life who cares if the moon's
going to crash into your planet brandon
says god's not real hey that's just one
man's opinion he's not wearing a helmet
right now he's living yeah yeah raw dog
i'm not gonna ask him to strike me down
or her to strike me down uh here's the
next headline for you she hulk said
writer jessica gao has reasons for
ignoring the blip uh it looks like they
haven't talked about it at all on
she-hulk and they're probably not going
to she said quote so many shows and
movies in the mcu have already kind of
covered that have they jessica i don't
know uh she also said so many people
have already covered that territory that
we've accepted it we live in a world
where that's already happened and people
have already moved on what is this
ghetto get over it they're back who
cares uh so she's saying that i think
there's been enough talking about it
we've heard that secret invasion is
going to cover some more blip stuff too
this mainly sounds like she just does
not want to get in it makes sense to
none of it like every property like you
would get redundant and if another show
is going to lean heavily into it it's
better to not be like we're bored of
hearing about the blip i think this is
smart and totally it doesn't really
unless they made it like a single punch
line which might be even worse than
ignoring it yeah as far as like impact
we've had we've had the pump punch line
in spider-man far from home yeah my wife
loved me she pretended to be blipped
like that's pretty epic that's pretty
heavy
good one uh i see our point too it's
such a heavy thing to conceptualize yeah
uh and if you had asked me you know
three years ago oh wouldn't they would
talk about all the time why wouldn't
they talk about this
altering event every second of every day
and here we are like let's go back to
concerts please
uh i just want to i just want to shout
out real fast not a lot of super chats
today that's okay it's friday you know
yeah i'm just right through it but these
are uh we we hacked the servers of
marvel uh studios and we found we found
real headlines that they were gonna can
we do one sample we didn't want to go
no maybe absolutely nothing
we got a freebie yesterday
yesterday give me a freebie
give them half of one
we always win chat we always win i'm
gonna give the whole thing okay okay
this is a real headline that was uh at
the bottom of a she-hulk episode you
might have missed madrapor sex syndicate
busted called
the ten [ __ ] rings oh my gosh that's too
salacious for disney plus oh my dad is
here watching
i'm gonna be bad it was dad's here this
is gonna be right if we raise 500 today
we'll have
but you might have me read one in front
of my father which is also pretty good
oh god
they're pretty intense and thank you for
the super chatters have already come in
match 143 saying omg ending my week with
anna
those might be heart eyes they could be
death tomatoes
i'll take both don't flatter me hit me
with those death eye okay actually i'm
not encouraging this but hi match good
to have you good to have you here uh
uh our next headline it's still in the
vein of she-hulk uh jessica gow also
confirmed where hulk spaceship is going
and i bet you can guess where it is uh
she said well all all i say is you know
he spent a lot of time off planet as we
saw in thor ragnarok and we only got to
see a little tiny bit of what his life
was like when he was on that planet so
it sounds like they're going back to
sakaar
booby boo uh and mark ruffalo pretty
much said the same thing uh because he
was he was asked about like his future
and what we see more of the hulk on the
car he gave a very long answer about it
basically saying like i would love to
cast your checks disney please please
please
say the real quote brandon the whole
quote in its entirety ruffalo we do a
show here and it only lasts an hour we
need you to be more brief yeah brief he
said money money money give me money
please
he said quote i don't know it certainly
does suggest that uh there's been a
there's been some conversations about
what happened in the two years where
hulk abandoned banner and the avengers
and the emergence of small smart hulk
which hasn't ever fully been answered uh
so i'm saying there's been conversations
is interesting i'm wondering during this
like 10-year meeting they had i'm sure
it came up at some point you know it
could be like a disney plus show right
like the the adventures of the
incredible hulk d23 announcement yeah
like the timing is is there and if we
get the universal you know rights back
next year which is the big heavy rumor
i'm not a lawyer i haven't seen the
paperwork but it does sound like that's
credible so if we get an announcement of
you know phase five and they just like
add one like
graphic like
do you think it might be a movie or a tv
show i think the budget would require a
movie uh just because you'd want you'd
want like you know a world war hulk of
the scope to rival ragnarok's like you
want a planet smashing hulk and if
you've got scar you're always kind of
cgi and him so now you're talking
multiple leads could never do two hog
type characters
jessica gao also confirmed that bruce
banner was only in human form in the
shanghai post-credits scene because
of shield
uh she just got paid the filmmakers off
of she-hulk i need
more stuff for my show please she's
proving that like no no no i wagged the
dog okay
uh they they made the she-hulk changes
because of me
uh but she was saying that uh she quote
we knew that we wanted him to bleed onto
jen which is how uh she got his blood
hulk would not bleed you can't hear hulk
skinned certainly not through a dinky
car accident so she was saying like we
need him to show up in shanghai as a
human to kind of set up like he's able
to be a
it's
human
again
also yeah and how much press did they
get about all going like why is it human
yeah yeah
there's not many videos out of that i
think it's really smart like disney does
a good job knowing what we want to see
that'll raise just enough questions like
would you like 18 commercials because
it's brilliant already with with them
giving hints of like maybe a word of the
world
okay and you know they already know like
the next three things so we're just like
here's the five videos of maybe i want
to have kevin feige just like go through
youtube and like yes no yes like
retroactively decide what was going to
ever be real yeah
it is interesting especially like this
on top of like the abomination story
yeah like oh yeah they put abomination
in because we they needed to remind the
audience for [ __ ] there was concept
art of deadpool in that fighting ring
which would have also been great but you
know not super they probably didn't know
where deadpool i love the idea of like
feige calling up the shang chi people
and being like look you guys need to put
a you got to put abomination in your
movie figure it out
not my problems
they gotta keep it going um uh yes oh we
got fifty dollars it's time for stuff to
read a headline listening to our super
chats like mike chiro saying cap [ __ ]
f ux i'm allowed to say that yeah uh it
was foreshadowing i thought he was
trying to say cap faux and i was like
four is that what we're doing he was
saying uh kev fox was foreshadowed for
the reveal of daddy hulk definitely
explains why banner wasn't around for so
long yeah i mean everyone is if it's not
shown that hulk has a little baby
everyone's gonna be sad no i like that
they're giving all the old avengers kids
now yeah that's very sweet they're
growing up they're growing up right
before our eyes
uh and uh
kristen unpronounceable nailed it i did
what do you guys think would be a good
dr doom mcu outfit uh we are going to do
some documentary fantastic but this is a
good question because like i think it's
kind of the og they keep trying can you
do a full metal math 100 you got to do
think about how good the man in the iron
mask looked like you've yeah we've done
it and we try to change it it always
looks bad like i think everything we've
seen on screen so far nothing moves on
the mask it's a solid okay the character
was created to resemble a skull and to
elicit that kind of response so a skull
doesn't move like a jaw moves but you
want that like isolated it makes it more
unnerving that something so growing and
condescending isn't moving like it's
it's pure arrogance like he stays stoic
and
skull-like arrogance and i think you
need that to translate like the the
ominous doom of doom kind of like how
like kang's face was like that it's just
this yeah like purple face darth vader i
mean classically right another is the
best example classic do you think doom
should have a full metal face that
doesn't move like wear a mask
do you find that unsettling would you
like a fan of
like a phantom of the opera situation
where you see half of a face here's what
i want i want doctor outfit oh
skull mask
but like just a cut out just to cut out
like paper medical school yeah
yeah what is that well back in the day
they didn't have like they needed a
light to be able to look into areas and
they would reflect the light off their
little things
to make it more 2022 2023 i want it
should be like an iphone attached to his
head with the flashlight i like that
yeah i like that i do like that i would
like some fan art please all right thank
you we got adriana for the costume
design for this new fantastic formula i
don't know you were gonna say for new
rockstars
are we only doing one per 50 no no last
last we'll give them two we'll give them
two this point please
give them two you want to give them to
you i'll do one of them
okay
these are real headlines it was too
disturbing these are real headlines
from she-hulk that cup
all hot women on the dating app revealed
to be same shape-shifter busy scroll oh
no busy scrolls
here's the headline here's the headline
they cut for she hulk and this is very
apropos she hulk
men everywhere buying green body pillows
and suffocating themselves in the quote
she-hulk challenge
that's why tommy jessica and zach are
out today yeah yep they failed
to die yeah
they just had severe brain damage oh no
uh yes thank you all our super chatters
like titan 29 uh he does say bruce does
mention genetics being part of the
transformation product process could the
hulk slash abominations be mutants
saying that like the reason that bruce
emile and jen can all kind of take this
uh uh hulkification is because they're
mutants they have like the genetic
disposition to accept it making bruce
banner mutant would be
huge spicy well you know very spicy the
the
uh incredible hulk film did sort of
imply that it was more of a super
soldier serum type situation
so then are you saying like you know all
the flag staffers all the flag flashers
are mutants cap is a mutant like do you
get into that conversation i don't i
don't hate this i mean the mutated gene
is hard to quantify like the the x gene
is what makes the mutants in the comic
books but
they had like so many issues about how
spider-man isn't a mutant and his genes
did change because the spider and
deadpool is technically not a mutant in
the comic books right so there's like a
fine line and it'd be interesting what
the mcu chooses to like distinguish that
especially since they they've been
introduced with a new character that
wasn't in the comic books so they
couldn't do that
with hulk yeah and then they made rick
choices where they're like uh
oh yeah uh uh neymar's a mutant yeah
he's a mutant well in the comics he's a
mutant right right they retroactively
are like first mutant yeah he's like
first one and i'm really curious how
that's gonna go and then they're like
what about apocalypse and they're like
well he's technically the first mutant
if you want to say that yeah because
they had to make it an x-men and i think
it's going to be interestingly messy
with playing with continuity to appease
fans of the comics versus making it work
linearly but like look at the civil war
i think the mcu does a really good job
playing the exact equalizer to make it
approachable but also like us to go oh i
get that reference i say make them all
now call it x-men babies
x-men babies
you're making your dreams conscious i
will say it all right
stop super chatting oh don't start
talking
the the interesting thing about miss
marvel right is that at one point uh she
was referred to as an enhanced
individual by the dodc and then they
were like oh your genes are mutated so i
think marvel is still kind of figuring
it out like we haven't really gotten
wanda to be called a mutant yet we here
they really hinted at that though but i
mean in miss marvel they threw in the
gentleman yeah i mean look i'm not
denying it i'm not denying that but but
they did start off calling around that
series enhanced right the dodc called
a few people enhanced individuals so who
knows i think we're going to see more
than one mutant revealed once they start
the cascade of it so the hulk would be a
huge thing but i do think it's going to
be like a domino that falls and then
it's going to be huge we've touched
before on the hulk saying in she-hulk
that their genes were specifically
different
did we end up anywhere on that well we
just don't know i mean until they say
like an x gene they're just like
genetically
different you know make it acceptable i
don't know we'll see and i mean d23 is
in a couple weeks yeah enhanced has been
their dirty word for mutant pro that's
their original dirty word for even
miracle children yeah you have a scarlet
witch post credit well that's you know
right yeah
that was a weird scene
and steve rogers says we have enhanced
on the field and they were two mutants
so
they might just make it like
children of the atom was like an iconic
and they've talked about how they might
not call it x-men i could see something
like that being a factor like once they
start cascading yeah
we're going to get to these super chats
uh
we got to do some more headlines before
i do the headlines let's do it real fast
get into it uh
you know what's important out there
folks it's keeping your mind happy and
healthy it's so important so why not
invest some time and money and energy
and doing just that our sponsor today
better help is here to help you keep
your mind healthy i'm a person that's
benefited from therapy in the past
believe it or not i wasn't perfect guys
can you believe it uh and i would
recommend therapy to anyone who's
looking for it you know it's it's a
great thing to try several people on the
new rockstar staff have you have used
better health uh to conduct their
therapy sessions and they really enjoy
it it's super convenient better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat only therapy sessions
because it's online you can do it from
anywhere where you feel most comfortable
you have to get in a car go to some
stranger's building uh my therapist was
in a van that flew through the sky uh
they even have the option to have the
camera turned off during your session so
you don't have to be on camera if you
don't want to you have to see anyone on
camera it's up to you
this is like a shady drug dealer from
the greece universe yeah that's exactly
what it is
yeah
great therapist uh
plus a good thing about better help is
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and right now our listeners get
10 off their first month at
break
betterhelp.com
that's better h-e-l-p dot com slash
break room uh before we get into our big
topic today our big discussion today we
got to do some headlines we owe double
headlines i believe this is really a sad
story oh okay
i was catfished by a 115 year old german
scientist woman explains her erotic
fling with quote man inside computer
we found this this was cut from the show
filthy it's these are real it's too
filthy too salacious but i happen to
find this song
uh this just in discovered underground
hidden room in stark mansion unearthed
new piece of erotic stark technology
named the i love you three thousand oh
it's coming i just love the sound of
erotic dark technology that just sounds
so official hey government officials
seen courting multiple women in bar with
the line quote i'm putting together a
team i love that
i love that one i just left out they got
a shout out
free another freebie
we'll give them this one atlantean man
drones 15 people at wet t-shirt contest
hosted at local buffalo wild wings
he's got tape too much too much water
too much water next headline
hey
if you've been on the internet today you
probably have found out that matt
shakman of one division has been uh is
in talks to uh direct the new upcoming
fantastic four movie uh schedule to come
out in
2024
um we want to talk about that right it's
very exciting it's very exciting you've
been rumored for a couple of weeks now
but we don't report on rumors because we
are upstanding of full source you know
it wasn't real we were like fun i
[Music]
got no response so that's that's that's
how i'm doing personally
i'm being monitored
that's right phones are tapped but uh
you know rumor uh insiders are not
telling deadline that while a formal
offer hasn't been presented early
discussions have begun
and they're headed in the right
direction right that's what we want to
hear um now here's the thing
jacqueline's doing a new star trek movie
um that's right we've got a date already
for
this new fantastic four movie
so for a long time we were like there's
no ann shackman he's doing this uh star
trek movie uh i hope the star trek movie
doesn't get pushed maybe it's a little
further along than thought that it was
but i just want to talk about fantastic
four real fast right and there's also
additional rumors that this might be
taking place in the 1960s that rumor
maybe originated when um
peyton reed gave an interview someone
was like hey what what other marvel
movie would you like to do and he was
like i would love to do a fantastic four
movie he said the 1960s but that has
sort of stuck around in the rumor mill
for a long time so um you know vos
actually eric voss has a tick tock now
he did a little tick talk about how you
know shackman
grew up doing sitcoms in
the
actor in some of these 1960s
which sort of got him his one vision job
and helped him with that but we saw a
bunch of 1960s stuff
in one division as they were sort of
going through the years um
so
i guess you know what do we think about
setting the movie in that time period it
kind of gets us around the whole like
what were they doing during all of these
bad things that were happening to earth
right problem maybe they're stuck in the
quantum realm or something like that you
know i want to hear from you guys you
know what do you think about that uh
could we see the fantastic four maybe
working with hank pym at camp lehigh
maybe they were in cahoots together
making pin particles
and they maybe got stuck in the quantum
realm or something like that uh give me
give me a quick thought koi i feel like
you've got a million opinions on this i
would have them i would have reid have
worked with hank i would have like some
people be aware of him as like a master
geneticist master scientist like big
brain and basically use that city that
we've teased a few times that we think
we're going into quantum mania i think
since we know that the fantastic four
aren't going to be introduced with the
year one they're going to be already
established because kevin feige said
that a couple weeks ago i would have
whoever you can be introduced in other
films because you don't want a team
movie unless you're somehow guarding the
galaxy which did it masterfully it's
hard to have everything at once so if
you can introduce them you know in a
piece in ant-man or put them you know
sprinkled throughout to build up to this
i would have them be from the 60s people
out of time and then they get out they
escape much like wasp has and then
they're still advanced showing how
intelligent he is he's able to catch up
he's able to have the fish out of water
sensibilities because this is marvel's
first family you want there to be
something that distinguishes them from
other teams i think a fun way to do that
is to have like a george clooney very
stoic type someone that's from another
time but in this world because you need
them to feel like a first family so
maybe they've been bonded together
trapped in the quantum realm they're
they're a unit and then they get out and
then you don't have to do the cosmic
radiation and stuff yeah and just to
like present a little bit of evidence
for that theory right like hey we have
peyton reed sort of
giving this interview it would be
interesting to see them show up in
ant-man and quantomania considering like
they sort of teased dr doom in was it
the first ant-man movie
where you had like that shot of janet
with the hood oh yeah and you were like
doom and then she pulls her head back
back and you're like oh it's just janet
yeah um so peyton reed's been sort of
teasing and he's a huge fan some
fantastic four stuff for a long time big
fan we have the this sort of quantum
realm city that is in the background
that we think is going to play a big
role in quantum mania that feels like a
perfect home and how could it be for
peyton reed since he you know
to introduce them like he's a giant like
fantastic force his team yeah he gets to
be the guy
i think that would be terrific um you
know uh what do you what do you guys
think do you think it's going to be
7960s do you think they'll do something
i think that multiversal if you do what
you're saying like you set them up in
the 60s and they got trapped in the
native zone and out of their back baby
and it's like
a situation like that or almost similar
to it'd be cool if they were from the
future and they come to this point in
the past to like fix some things that
are a problem and kind of like escape
from planet of the apes style yeah we're
from the future and we know things get
bad i do like them bringing in
manchegoment if that means they want to
include a little bit of wanda maximoff
with his showing his expertise how he's
handled the scarlet witch
what she did in multiverse of madness if
like the rest of the family comes to our
universe looking for revenge i like the
idea that we don't have the fantastic
four because of kang
you know
whatever pruning he was doing on the
timeline kept them out of our universe
because like maybe you know rich reid or
sue storm or any of them is like the
biggest foil for kang he's like if i can
keep my own if he who remains can have
an own universe where he keeps out the
other kings and keeps the threat from
the inside low yeah then he can just
kind of exist here yeah let's talk about
some of those one division you know
connections to a fantastic four movie
potentially right like there was um
you know monica rambo was like i know
this aerospace engineer who can help us
out people thought that was reid
richards it didn't end up being read
rich it's just like some extra
ah
but you know that was some fun
speculation uh ralph boner style there
um
we also had um
we also had hayward in the beginning of
that movie sort of say like oh yeah we
lost some of our best astronauts in the
blip uh that's a very sad story i think
like mcu logic says that like bruce
banner when he did the reverse snap sort
of like put everyone back safely right
like that is sort of a weird way i took
that to be that like because half of
nasa or a big portion of nasa got wiped
out people in space suffered like they
didn't get blind
they just died
so you know maybe if it's maybe if it is
the fantastic four and reid richards can
like put some gum on a you know
telescope or something and shoot them
into another they've been like lost in
space because they're like still alive
somehow and they're just needing to be
rescued i saw a super chat come in that
said uh fantastic four as a help style
movie uh i have not seen that's a
beatles movie if anyone's curious i've
not seen that movie but when when i saw
it as a help style movie uh a rescue
mission was the first thing that that
popped to my mind obviously a little bit
different from that um movie but that
would be very interesting to see like oh
the fantastic four needing to be rescued
is like an interesting uh
interesting thought there but you talked
to me about something earlier today
which i think is also really cool which
is like okay
we have a reed richards that is dead
in earth a38 right he has a family we
know that like
talking through like what is your what
is your pitch you maybe have wanna come
in you have their family
yeah or like their family comes to r to
616 either looking for wanda or just to
warn whatever
version of the fantastic four exist here
like hey you need to deal with wanda
she's a problem something like that i
don't know i want i'm ready for marvel
to like really start messing with these
characters like i want them to make sue
storm be mrs fantastic and
richards be the invisible man and like
swap what powers and abilities like
makes you storm the like
mastermind genius uh and not read
wretches like kind of play with things a
little bit so i don't want to see a
story that we already know how it ends
my main trickiness with my time displays
thing which i do think would be fun is
doom and namor because i do want the
relationship with sue and namor to be
pregnant and i do want the latverian
concept of like him being worshipped and
like i do think black panther is the way
to do that i honestly think i would
introduce doom through black panther but
i don't know what that would mean for
time displacement so like there are
things that work in things that don't
but no matter what i want sue to be
a force in this yeah because sue was
such an interesting character in the
comic books but when not written well
they just kind of like read and friends
it's kind of like the wolverine the
x-men problem yeah yeah there's always
like the one character like it's a team
yeah
well and you know what i also think is
interesting is can we pull up that phase
six graphic real fast daschle if we
still have that
you know okay
phase fours five and six are are going
to be now called the multiverse saga i
think it's really important to say like
hey this is where that fantastic four
movie is sitting on the timeline of
films obviously there's a few things
that are going to come between this
movie and kang dynasty but
there's no doubt in my mind
that this story is going to be heavy on
the multiverse i think this kicks off
basics for a reason but i also think
that's going to double in two weeks oh
of course like i think we're going to
see like a lot of changes when we have
this like hometown advantage because i
feel like i mean you you have a comic
con and that's and i'm so proud and
happy for comic fans to have had the
comic con experience we did with marvel
but there's no way they didn't go like
we're saving some stuff
and that was the rumor right for a long
time was that d23 was or comic-con was
going to be a smaller show not a lot of
announcements because they wanted to
save a lot of stuff for d23
that still could be true well i think it
is they've done 60 things right right
like we're gonna do 20 at comic-con
we've got 40 like they can really do
whatever they want but i think this
kicking off basics is really important
because you if you look at the way these
universes are shaped and these phases
are shaped it usually ends with like an
avenger event right and then you've got
like the denouement sometimes like iron
man three but you really have that
kickoff with fantastic four i think we
need to know them know them by then and
i think that that way
yeah so whether it's you know ant-man or
or you know having doom introduced i
think in november i think we need to
have established that world so when that
team takes off we're already invested in
that as a kickoff yeah my head cannon
for what kind of forever is that like
neymar's pissed
at uh wakanda for being like hey we're a
secret city and now we're open we're
gonna share everything and all the other
secret cities are gonna be like you
weren't supposed to do that
i think the end of the movie they should
just have you know atlanta's or
talon or whatever they're calling it now
and then have that various show up yeah
have lumeria show up like everything
else just shows up at once and we get 50
new hidden cities
yeah the league of the league of hidden
cities is like screw this guys it was
really nice we're having such a fun time
uh we've got so many super chats coming
in we got to get through some of these
super chats we got to get the next
tourney hemlock we got a real big show
today and in a minute coy's going to
laugh in a minute
we're going to be casting this new
fantastic yeah we're going to do
something
let's see you're fan casting in the chat
okay do one yeah deranged former god
butcher has change of heart
demands
all gods must come oh my gosh that's
inappropriate hey he was he didn't get
invited to omnipotence
he's a little sad he didn't get it wrong
why aren't you
guys speaking of comedy
um
he looks asleep uh it's important to get
a good night's sleep right and nothing
helps you achieve the perfect
night's sleep like the right mattress
that's why we want to thank our friends
and he likes sleep helix sleep has this
great
a little bit of something i gotta go
sorry
i'm taking this quiz it really does just
take two minutes to complete matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences talking about like are you a
side sleeper are you a back sleeper that
kind of thing um do you sleep with a
partner really cool um
um
and it sort of
it says like hey this is a mattress that
we make that we think would be great for
you um why would you buy a mattress from
for someone else i disagree with tommy i
think kids should be buying their own
mattresses yeah make them rna yeah um
look everyone is unique helix knows that
so they have a bunch of different
mattress models to choose from they've
got soft medium and firm mattresses
madness mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot or you live in
los angeles where it's a thousand
degrees every night mattress is good for
spinal alignment if you're like koi you
have scoliosis and you've been uh you
know putting up for a year
can you just say that i just got uh
what's that thing sorry i got it so
i do have a helix mattress and i've said
this before i use it i'm taking it
koi wants it i did have a mattress from
a competitor and i'm so glad that i
switched to a healthy mattress this is
not a joke the competitor's mattress is
leaning against the wall in my bedroom
uh and i cannot sell it no one wants it
it's very upsetting please someone buy
my mattress
um
it's incredible uh zach and i got helix
mattresses at the same time
he was having a child i texted him i
asked him if he had set his mattress up
yet he said no i said you need to do
yourself a favor and set up your
freaking mattress just take the quiz and
order the mattress that you're matched
to and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again it
comes in this little tube it's very fun
just go to helixly.com break room take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
entire life well at least for the next
10 years because they have a 10 year
warranty you get to try out the mattress
for 100 nights risk free if you don't
like it they'll pick it up for you uh
but you're gonna like it because it's
great i mean that helix even has
financing options mattresses can be kind
of pricey
and flexible payment plans so you can
get good sleep now and pay for it
over the course of a few months great um
super smart that was a good way to
rephrase it's a tricky way to rephrase
what the teleprompter said i liked it i
liked it there's no teleprompter this is
all off the dome
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattresses and
two free pillows the pillow
for our listeners and their viewers at
helix sleep.com
break room that was great thank you yes
and thanks to our super chatters out
there like matthew harris thanks for
sending your super chat lewis coxing koi
is awesome he's a free one you know
that's subjective i guess true hey guys
breaking news breaking news scarlet
witch seemed seen arm-in-arm with hot
new boo after breakup suggesting quote
it was agatha
all along oh
super chat saying i think she-hulk is
going to replace the thing oh do you i
think not
uh
jiren 2003 senator super chat saying f4
is a help style movie you already called
that out uh
uh and holy sf said in a super chat
asking would jen represent peter better
than the than daredevil he's he's a
great attorney i don't know i don't know
i don't know if jen could have caught
that brick she doesn't have the same
kind of power get out here catching
strays wow not even representing peter
hey one more thing we got to talk about
real quick is that it's friday uh which
is which means it's time for another
fresh face friday brought to you by our
good friends at geology this is the
segment where we shine to spotlight on a
fresh face to the mcu today we're
calling out josh sagara who plays
augustus pug pugsley that's a cute man
he is a very
good looking man so funny while josh
might be new to the mcu he's been all
over your streaming services playing a
variety of characters and range of types
like this guy could do it all man most
recently he was on hbo max series called
the other two
he is so funny on that show really good
but he's also played ceo stefanovic is
that you saying that stefan vick on
orange is the new black eye game after
gave up after two seasons chancellor
genji kota can't handle a show after two
seasons it just gets on bld it gets
unwieldy uh but hey some of you
arrowheads out there is that what you're
called i hope so from the arrowverse uh
he was adrian chase in the arrowverse
hey i don't know what that means
i didn't watch arrow i'm sorry i watched
every episode of everything are they
called arrowheads
arrowheads go back in time and get the
movement going uh hey and when you have
to jump ips to play a lawyer you want to
make sure that when you deliver that
closing argument your face is smooth
healthy and hydrated if you want to keep
keep your face looking as fresh as pug
good luck he's a beautiful man but you
can also check out the great skin care
products at geology you can take a quiz
we love we love quizzes you love quizzes
you take a quiz uh boom uh uh at
geology.com new rockstars take that quiz
at geology.com new rockstars and they'll
suggest the perfect lineup of skincare
items for you chrissy says he was in
prometheus was he the weird skin skins
too much jealous he did so many things i
couldn't list them all on the imdb i
just did a quick quick quick drive-by uh
but yeah please go to head uh head on
over to geology.com new rockstars and
use our promo code rockstar 70 to save
70 off on a 30-day trial of geology
that's rockstar 70 at uh geology.com new
rockstars to get 70 off on a 30-day
trial holy holy well before we jump into
the next segment we we did hit we needed
two more headlines
at 300 i'll take the next one thank you
thank you for all these super chats
these are great these were cut these
were cut from she-hulk for being
super
too
two dwarfs to play her
children billy and tommy i don't know if
you can say that on tv
wrote that one please don't quit
billionaire arrested for exposing
himself at grocery store while yelling
i'm bringing the party to you
i love that he's dead how could they say
stuff about it you're doing a third it's
bad well you can't stop it run it out oh
i like this one i like this one local
elderly professor arrested for air
dropping nude images into people's minds
i love that one clever it's very good
professor sex
oh
yeah get back to brandon's camera
do you want to say it again
okay
well let's move on because our amazing
hey hey where's hey
it's time for manchester united
you pushed the camera away i can't
believe john stole it from me because
tommy's not ignoring he just said i'm
playing my graphic no
oh my gosh oh god you know what y'all in
front of our father in front of my
father he cuts me in front of my boss he
still doesn't have a first name don't
know if he's real or a paid actor just
saying i think stop cutting to john it's
me it's me damn it
i think that uh graphic was broken so
let's put it on rice and play it twice
let's go play the graphic
now y'all been doing some crimes so we
gonna play it three times play the
grammy
did you write these before you came in
today
in the mirror no okay that's what that
sound was we're talking fantastic four
so let's play it once more
all right i thought we were out of it
all right four times that's good that's
good i'm done with that so
in honor of matt shackman possibly
taking the reins on the fantastic four
film we wanted to do a little a little
recasting for him doing a solid help him
out uh and come up with some of the
rules for him yes now he's directed tons
of shows and films and so to add a
little extra layer of challenge we
decided to or i want to hear y'all's
decisions in casting these roles using
only actors that he has worked with in
the past
shows and movies so it's time
to do the fantastic
how about like fan cast flick
for four all right
in the middle too much you didn't even
give the bit a chance to fly okay the
fantastic four that's take one take two
uh use this if you don't like the first
one this is live the fantastic flick no
you're right the first one is
two minutes
fantastic who's going first fantastic
four okay i can i can go first i can go
first this one is kind of easy because
shackman's directed so much stuff i
wrote down little things that remind me
he's directed so many things uh okay i'm
gonna start off with my my my sue and my
read back to back
and they already worked together on one
of his shows that he directed he
directed a couple episodes of the great
if you haven't seen it it's great
uh it's really good but i think we'll go
with our leads there for our reid
richards we'll do nicholas hall you
might remember him he's a little beasty
boy i'm doing young i'm doing a young
richard and a young sue okay
this is our richard he's giving me a
nicholas fault and then elf fanning as
sue storm i mean this is a terrible
photo of her apologies
down find my light find my life l
fanning it's two storm these two
together they're great on the show they
got good chemistry they bicker which is
like nice they get along which is good
it'll be fun now they're young okay but
i'm going older with the other people
but the idea of this film being that
like sue and richard are seen as the
young scientists coming around they're
pushing the boundaries and their friends
and her brother and and everyone else
they're older and they're telling you to
tell them you can't do that you can't be
that crazy uh and they're trying to stop
them her brother sue's brother johnny
storm uh the human torch if you will
he's gonna be you know him you'll love
him he was on one tree hill which matt
jackman did some directing of chad
michael murray oh no
i'm looking like an older an older human
torch right susan
my ex-girlfriend is going to make me
watch the new fantastic four movies now
now their good friend ben grimm also an
older man tired of putting up with the
bs can't stand these kids going around
you know i'm from billions it's paul
giamatti folks paul giamatti as an angry
ben graham being like i don't want to be
a rock no one can love me only a blind
lady could love this ugly rock man i
love obsessed that'd be great now who is
there dr doom well you might know him
from an episode of the good wife
called iowa that was the name of the
episode this was an episode that matt
jackman directed
jeffrey dean morgan baby oh he's in the
boys as victor von doom season he's
coming into the witch uh
he's also directed
so that's that's my shackman cast for
fantastic four so um
hey i have a confession
i did this wrong oh okay uh i thought we
were doing like a kevin bacon six
degrees of separation thing i'm just
getting a flashlight i have flowcharts
and i have i have this way
i took a long time because i really
wanted to get into it
so here's here's um here's my first pick
um matt jackman did directed this movie
called cut bank which is really good it
started uh it started a man named edward
zwick
he's going so it was in a movie called
defiance okay um
which starred jamie bell now you may
remember jamie bell as
um ben grimm from the fantastic four
movie in 2015.
jamie bell is that ben grimm i can't uh
one of the one of the other okay
this is the right side up uh if you're
going to keep one person from that
original movie i think you know you're
saying it's reflecting yeah you still
whenever you just tilt it down
there you go is that best
yeah that's right put my head behind it
thank you if you're going to kick one
person you might as well do that okay um
but if you're going bring him if you're
gonna keep two people um you know if you
must mash ackman directed this movie
called cut bank
which started an actress named teresa
palmer who was in the sorcerer's
apprentice okay with tony cabell
if you'll remember too many photos
you played doctor news yep played doctor
doom in that uh 2015 movie
okay
all right so if you're gonna keep if
you're gonna keep two people from that
movie i think you should keep so far
you've kept everything two people of the
country
i thought it was a good movie from the
josh strength movie right now one of the
worst categories hold on half printed
like the ink is around this one because
even the printer doesn't want it nice
matt shackman directed a movie called
cut bank starring liam hemsworth who is
in the hunger games
with deo okanay who is also in the
spectacular now okay with miles teller
reed richards so you're keeping him as
well keep read richard's mouth's telling
what's happening here here we go
we're getting the movie again
it was really good starring brewster
excellent i like it excellent excellent
actor who was in a in a show i think
called chappaquiddick okay with
k-mart
right who stays excellent
if we're going to keep one person in
this movie k-mart incredible actress
right what's happened and then
to round it out to round it out
okay
matt shackman directed this movie called
cut bank
which starred billy bob thornton who was
in a simple plan with a man named adam
schroeder
who was in chronicle great movie we can
all agree with
with
jonathan bliss oh my gosh michael b
jordan he's been in the mcu before i
recognize that but so have other people
so john watched cut bank today
really good what's this really good
flick you wasted so much i feel like
i was very stressed before the show and
i was supposed to write the discussion
for the other segment
can i can i
show this
yeah look at what we're working with
here guys i did cast this so if you want
to if you want to stick around there's
still more cutouts all right that's it
that's it
that's my list okay so we're keeping
josh fantastic okay okay i'm not i've
decided to cast based off people that
have worked with matt shachman that have
not yet been in fantastic four uh i went
with the leads i gave two options one
older one younger but only about a
10-year spread because you know
so uh with the
always great always sunny in
philadelphia
i think glenn howerton would
authentically make a great mr fantastic
he's got an arrogance about him but he's
also inherently charming uh there is a
want he has said he stayed in shape
because he's always wanted to play a
superhero he also was the number two
pick for star-lord after chris pratt so
they're familiar with them i
legitimately think glenn howard should
be great uh if they go a little younger
the great nat wolf has also worked with
matt shakman i think he'd be solid i
think glenn howerton by number one pick
but little a little younger i don't
think they should do a young fantastic
four they've tried twice didn't work out
but if they do do younger uh i'm gonna
go with miss d'addario as a sue storm
who has worked with matt shakman she has
not done anything super heroic yet and i
also think she is able to convey the
very intelligent while also being very
superhero stunning which is a hard line
to walk we've seen a lot of 90s movies
but they could not do that i think she
can but i would prefer an older sioux
storm a fully adult sue storm and i
think from the boys the always
incredible underrated karen fukahara
this woman does not get enough credit
she is so talented has such a presence
has just a nest about her she reads is
very intelligent which is important when
combating reid's intelligence so those
are my younger and older pick for these
now with uh johnny it's very important
they be both sassy but heartwarming they
need to be charming but also
braggadocious they need to be the comic
relief but you also have to like them
who better than mac rob mcelini would be
such a good human torch but if they
don't want mac they've also got he was
in one episode of always sunny you got
sean williams scott it's uh it's
definitely my 90s
we are gonna only have one casting
option for the thing because it's a
voice roll this one uh did one guest
star on always stunning phil sunny in
philadelphia he's ted lasso i'd love to
hear jason sudakis's voice because you
want someone that has presents you want
i'm not gonna deliver i'm gonna uh
checklist it put a dude under the suit i
want this
and then uh for dr doom i've got two
options for you he was in growing pains
with matt schachman he has yet to dive
into super heroics i think it'd be an
actually solid twist on the genre to get
someone that's usually a good guy who
we've seen in certain tarantino films
played bad guy we got leonardo dicaprio
uh i think the only way you get him to
do a superhero movie is to give him
something juicy have him something to
chew on and that's dr doom if not him mr
shachman has also worked with christoph
waltz as he produced the recent show i
think it's called the consultant this
man's voice coming out of that doom
skull would be absolutely incredible but
you cannot talk about always sunny in
philadelphia without bringing up the
mole man you cast dated to me to his
mole man i'm paying whatever amount of
money on imax to see that movie that is
my matt shackman cast
i feel like you took that really
seriously i take everything seriously uh
i took it seriously dude
i have a real one from cup bank in your
case cut bank's own sean wing of
scotland
there you go okay i did do a real one i
did do a real one well we don't have
time you don't want to hear it
mary elizabeth winstead she's going to
place you storm shoes in fargo match
have been directed right here we go uh
i don't remember how to pronounce this
guy's name nikolaj costa waldo for sure
he was in game of thrones he's my pick
for johnny
mookie in the chat once howard stern is
doom
who is going to be in the upcoming
shackman this is a tiny picture
baseball
doctor doom upcoming shackman star trek
movie uh he's my reed richards i don't
care your wallet
it's so tiny
i've got two options for doom i'm trying
to do this quickly i've got two options
for dude i've got hugh laurie who was
in-house right shackman directed a lot
of episodes of would be fun but my pick
is it's morbid time jared harris a great
villain a great villain i want to see
him be evil i'm you know how's that
gotta get him in the end he's amazing
yeah i think the best for last
i say we give the cast of mormies just
another run at it and we just cast three
casts
all with the cast of morbius i got one
last pick oh it's my ben grimm okay
he was in shackman's upcoming
chippendales show
he's
which one do you want to see or do you
just want to see the cast of morbius
again in in those roles
who can't be escaped and thank you to
all our superintendents today we had so
many good super chats uh fred girl
sending in a super chat well we see
shang chi and katie and she-hulk also
koi is your shirt from killing joke it
is this is the last page of killing joke
one of the best
book history yeah
just right there just walk around
don't watch the animated version where
they make it yeah
it's weird it's weird uh
trash bag standing in a super chat i
think marvel does not trust ruffalo with
the information on a world war hope
movie so he's in the dark about it he's
just going to the bank baby uh how crazy
would it be if doctor doom used an iron
man helmet for his skull mask
says lion of demise that's a free one
for you kevin frank
thank you so much cool trainer huffy
saying the break room is the highlight
of my day thanks for getting us trash
bags through the day hey and thank you
guys for getting us through the day we
love doing this show we love being with
you
here with you every weekday uh but we
hope you guys have a great weekend it is
a friday thank goodness it's friday
don't laugh babe don't laugh at the
headlines oh we can't end till the poll
is done
here we go former famed surgeon post
bizarre tribute to x i've seen 14
million 605 possible futures and in
every single one i give you an orgasm
christine
how dare you run out on my boy
thank you guys for joining us today here
on the break room it looks like cory
might be running away with this paul a
bunch of koi heads in the chat are you
arrowhead answer the question
how could you not be arrowheads
i don't know work through it john
check us out on tic tac we're at the
underscore break room tommy's always
putting some good tick tockies on there
uh join the discord if you haven't
already uh you can find our clip you can
submit a clip of the week there we did
not do it again this week we'll give you
three next videos
clips of the week you can also send in
voicemails we're gonna start putting
those voicemails in on this show soon
paul coming in coy running away with it
uh
john john split his vote on his cut and
doesn't deserve broadcasting uh
and and we did ask you guys in the chat
are you tired of seeing marvel stories
based around the blip and 65 percent of
you said no take that jessica gao we
want more answers i want to blame i want
a four-hour documentary by ken burns
explaining everything about the blip to
me hundreds of robot corpses found
sodomizing new jersey dumpster oh boy
that's white vision running around
trying to figure himself out
thank you guys for joining us today on a
friday we hope you have a great weekend
join us here again on monday we got a
big week next week baby uh and september
is about to get crazy crazy we're gonna
have so much to talk about uh we hope
you guys have a great weekend thank you
for joining us adios latest gators we'll
see you later